it is the biggest movie franchise of all
time earning more than 25 billion
dollars worldwide tonight we celebrate
All Things Marvel welcome to
Entertainment Tonight this may be my
favorite show of all time because you
know E.T has been with the MCU stars
from the very beginning long before they
were ever marvelous
yeah that'll be my one self-indulging
statement yes I'm a damn hoot
you know what it's because I needed the
orange ball that was the green ball I'm
a very good driver I don't have my
permit yet but I will soon
so watch out New York I'm going to be
cruising the street soon
hi I'm Chris Pratt here with Everwood
now is this your first Academy Award
the first thing that goes through my
mind is oh my God my father has to swear
to me he's going to close his eyes when
he sees these Brad Pitt caves to the
screening to the premiere yesterday I
love Brad Pitt I'm stumbling I don't
know what to say
Robert Downey Jr may have started it all
with the very first Iron Man movie in
2008 but we first met him in 1987. when
I started out I was just like yes B film
yeah B part I love it yeah
I was just happy to be working he was
dating Sarah Jessica Parker and just
about to release his breakout film less
than zero my actors are so insecure you
know I mean I I was thinking about I
kept saying oh I look so shiny in that
ooh or you know oh there was a lot of
this oh and sitting with people some
people enjoyed it or you know but then
you start wondering if your friends are
just gonna say yeah you were a killer
you know rdj's now worth the reported
300 million dollars thanks to his
massive Marvel success but he's not the
only one with an enviable end game
that's a strike in my book Captain
America AKA Chris Evans is the sexiest
man alive now but he was the
All-American jock in 2001's Not Another
Teen Movie he didn't know it then but he
was gearing up to be a superhero
if I end up doing more movies with
stunts I think I'll probably invest in
some stunt classes you know I think it
must be learned it's not something you
can just Wan you can't just you know
have some courage and think you can get
away with it that is America's ass I was
emceeing Bar Mitzvah receptions Ant-Man
Paul Rudd's Big Break was on the TV
series sisters in 1992 but at 23 he
didn't think he'd end up being one of
the seven Marvel stars named sexiest man
alive I don't think it ever will it
never has in my life and then I don't
think it'll happen though
Black Widow Scarlett Johansson was the
first actor to Executive produce her own
Marvel movie but when we met her she was
just 14 years old and telling us all
about learning to horseback ride for The
Horse Whisperer the first couple of
weeks I was in pain of course but other
than that I never really had any doubts
eternals Angelina Jolie was just another
10 year old on the Oscar red carpet with
her dad are you nervous for your dad
tonight
Angie's co-star Salma Hayek was sinking
her teeth into George Clooney on the
1995 setup From Dusk Till Dawn she told
us back then her parents weren't
thrilled when she moved to LA to follow
her dreams it's like why did you do this
you know just get married settle down we
want grandchildren I'm like no no I'm
going to Hollywood I'm trying to keep it
like like I have a student who does
movies on the side you know not like
someone who does movies and does school
all the side that's a 13 year old
Natalie Portman before she bulked up for
Thor and even though she turned into an
oscar-winning actress she kept her word
and graduated from Harvard
I need to act I need to be an actor for
this audition and yeah Star-Lord Chris
Pratt sounded a lot like his future
father-in-law when we first met him on
the Everwood set 20 years ago and all
that dancing we see in the Guardians
outtakes well he's been practicing those
moves since the very beginning a little
sample of some singing and dancing like
maybe a little Michael Jackson
I know you're not going to play this I
can say whatever I want
but here's the thing about Marvel movies
that we love our favorite superheroes
are also Super Friends on screen and off
just the two of us girls I have to watch
out for all the time she tries to trip
me a lot
um into giving me hugs
yeah yeah it ain't your beauty it's your
booty that's right I just want him to be
like you topping the best buddies list
rdj's tight bond with Spider-Man Tom
Holland just don't call it a romance
it's not a hug I'm just grabbing the
door for you well me and Downey isn't
really a bromance it's like a father-son
Mance which is a little creepy well not
creepy at all is scarjo's friendship
with Florence Pugh who made so much fun
of black widow's superhero pose off
camera it became a running gag in the
movie
[Music]
like you know sisters for a really long
time right that's what I keep on telling
Paula
he's like you're the sister I never
wanted
he's like I don't want to adopt you get
out of my house of course you can't talk
about scar Joe without talking about her
longtime friendship with Chris Evans
they bonded in 2004 on the set of the
Perfect Score way before cap met Natasha
we need your help we've been friends for
a long time so it's exciting to be able
to be with him on this and of course we
were on all the sets with all the
Avengers over the years starting way
back in 2007 with RDJ I am Iron Man
[Music]
come on now Iron Man hey what's up
you see me at my very most Butch
I was making out with Gwyneth Paltrow no
Tony was kissing Pepper Potts but at the
same time
where's the hammer yeah
it's buried somewhere in the field
[Music]
we're on a motorcycle it's not me I
can't ride a bike
wish you could try it
I lost um 16 pounds to do this part I'm
training all the time the thing is there
are some guys uh Chris Evans and
Hemsworth who are just so gargantuan
[Music]
it doesn't get any easier it's still you
know two chicken breasts brown rice
vegetables hour later you know more of
the same you just are constantly kind of
full I'm just stuffing myself with like
you know Bland chicken and you're just
like
just gotta lie down for a minute I
wouldn't say necessarily that you put on
a latex cat suit and go man this feels
great to be back in this thing
the worst thing is being my wife when
we're shooting because I occasionally
come home acting like a billionaire
[Music]
I think every little kid wanted to be a
superhero at some point but no you never
you never anticipate that it'll actually
work out
you know it's funny when I got into the
business my first meeting with my agent
I said I want to be a superhero
do I have any of the same qualities as
Peter Quill or Star-Lord yeah I suppose
I mean we're both devilishly handsome
[Music]
I told my own son that I was going to be
in a superhero movie and I said Ant-Man
and he he was not that impressed
what he actually said was well I can't
wait to see how stupid that'll be
[Music]
Entertainment Tonight hey welcome
everybody to new house God we're
basically just like calling destruction
here look at this
me show you how it's done
it's got the street thugs aren't we
the entire cruise looking at us saying
those guys are morons
well from onset Shenanigans to Onset
romances the Marvel Universe has given
us some serious relationship goals
I think Zendaya just showed up
yes my spider Lord
Tom Holland stopped to watch his lady
love Zendaya slay the red carpet for a
full 25 seconds before coming back to
our interview oh she's going in she's
going in she's gone in she's gone
I think it's great to have that support
and that love around you the couple met
on the 2016 set of Spider-Man homecoming
and were rumored to be dating the
following year but it wasn't until 2021
when the duo was spotted kissing in his
car but we knew something was up when
Tom told us about borrowings Zendaya's
jacket I still have it I even saw her in
New York like two days ago she's like
can I have the jacket back I was like
yeah I don't I don't know where it is
but when it comes to being friendly exes
Emma Stone and Andrew Garfield have our
Spidey senses tingling she's just a son
and um but she's and she's got such
depth she can do anything
you know uh she's magic I don't know how
she does it
[Music]
a real life couple after playing one in
The Amazing Spider-Man they dated for
four years before Calling it Quits but
these two are still tight we met uh the
screen test and uh
we we we just had a giggle we just we
just lost a lot and and kind of didn't
take it seriously and that was actually
the best the best way to do it he's just
he's just he's incredible
foreign
sixth Avenger cemented their legendary
status in Hollywood back in 2019 now the
Stars weren't only celebrated for their
accomplishments on screen but for using
their real-life powers to give back
behind the scenes
I mean it's one thing to be a superhero
on screen to them but when they look at
you and you're a bit of a hero off
screen that's got to make you feel
really good it does absolutely and and
sometimes you have to explain they're
like who are you it's like Thor they're
like where's the hammer and the long
hair and the outfit
who's Spider-Man how you doing
anything that we can do to make a
special day and to make your lives
easier
[Music]
more than anyone in more than any time
now is the time to give back to these uh
courageous kids who really Inspire us
this is a real honor for us to be able
to give back at least something yeah
we've seen firsthand the real life Good
Deeds Done by these superheroes from
spending the day with disadvantaged kids
at Disney parks to surprise hospital
visits from Captain America Star-Lord
and Spider-Man
but for dads like Chris Hemsworth and
Jeremy Renner it's also a chance to
teach their own kids the importance of
giving back it's really I make her do it
you know with uh for sure to give her
toys away to kids that don't know right
that's I shouldn't see me do it she
didn't know I'm an actor
she doesn't know she's on Hawkeye and
then I'm on her pajamas you know what I
mean you want your kids to be respectful
and conned and have empathy but but uh
it's also just to have great
appreciation you know and and not ever
take things for granted and there's you
know that's the thing that we try to
instill in them and the thing that my
parents instilled in us and taught us
and I'm incredibly grateful for I like
that attitude Thor all right now to the
Avenger whose impact is still being felt
to this day Chadwick Boseman how long do
you think you can keep your friend
2016's Captain America Civil War was the
first time Chadwick Boseman appeared as
t'challa Black Panther in the MCU now
two years later fans around the world
were immersed in the world of wakanda
and the power of Black Panther the Blick
Panther this is a festive experience you
know people are talking about
dressing up in African GARP to go to the
theater
I don't think we've ever seen that
before it's the only Marvel movie to
ever be nominated for a Best Picture
Oscar its leading man gone far too soon
Chadwick Boseman was just 43 years old
when he lost his four-year battle with
colon cancer no one knew it at the time
but he was in treatment throughout
filming and still held his own against
Michael B Jordan
he has a lot of physical activity that I
have to do as a whole and
if I can do that I'm gonna be in shape I
was less concerned about like you know
whether my bicep was as big as his bicep
Chad was pretty like you know he's
pretty athletic man he's very limber and
very like his martial arts is definitely
there but Chadwick left an impact not
just on the Marvel Universe he helped
make movie history Chadwick is just a
Powerhouse he really is so talented he's
such a Soulful actor and
um so professional and so present
Chadwick is a he's a really smart
interesting Dynamic guy and I think he
was not overwhelmed but very surprised
and somewhat taken aback by the amount
of love this welcome is is one of the
most amazing things I've ever
experienced his legacy continues and I'm
just happy that uh he has meant so much
to us that will continue to do that when
Chadwick died I mean I was lost for for
a few months there he was so for the
call sure he was so four people and for
uh rising up and and being the best we
could be so far the Black Panther films
have earned over 2.1 billion dollars
worldwide breaking records improving
strong female characters and a
predominantly Black cast can deliver at
the box office it's the kind of Legacy
Chadwick's Widow Simone ledward Bozeman
believes her husband would be proud of
Chad very clearly still has a huge
impact on people and and all we want to
do is make sure that that Legacy
continues
Chadwick's loss is still felt so
strongly in the MCU as is the passing of
producer Stan Lee who would have turned
100 today but fans still get to see him
in his 37 cameos how don't you move my
hands aren't as steady as they used to
be great
[Music]
and thanks to the Marvel Multiverse
there was this multi-spiderman moment
that no one saw coming Toby Maguire and
Andrew Garfield teaming up with Tom
Holland
I love you guys it was so much fun I
can't believe I still can't believe it
it happened
[Music]
[Applause]
I snuck into a theater one like on
opening night
and just watched from like with my
baseball cap on and my mask and just
kind of like and uh in fact I was
actually with Toby the guys even
recreated this viral meme I must have
got one
good shot because we were all just
cracking up so much we couldn't quite
contain ourselves the biggest surprise
Cameo John Krasinski as Reed Richards in
Doctor Strange in the Multiverse of
Madness
Hello Steven
some of our other favorite celeb
appearances well that's Kim Jong as a
security guard in in-game and Olivia
Munn as a reporter in Iron Man 2. and
there's that time Kurt Russell
shape-shifted into David Hasselhoff in
the guardian sequel I tried so hard to
find the form that best suited you
but there's one recurring role that
started out as a joke between friends
Chris Hemsworth thought it would be
funny to have his brother Luke and buddy
Matt Damon make an appearance as theater
actors in Thor Ragnarok and Thor love
and thunder Anonymous portal has
appeared behind us truthful
listen it's no secret that Marvel movies
dominate the box office but now they've
got a hold on streaming too thanks to
the superhero spin-offs that introduced
us to Marvel on TV tonight everybody see
y'all
we are an unusual couple you know it was
so wild and fun to really lean into all
of these
guys very excited that you know we're
gonna tell a story in six hours from
Hawkeye and the emmy-winning one
division to She-Hulk and Miss Marvel the
superhero sagas continue all the
multi-episode series are available on
Disney plus including the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier and Loki evil Loki's
master plan comes together it's been a
source of constant surprise and Delight
that I've played this character for so
long it's been an amazing ride
foreign